今天我们来进一步的讲述这个相关的一个议题,那么关于这个也还是这个认内交易的,那么在认内交易里面的话其实做法也很多,那么这里的话也在说一说那么其实跟我们之前讲的课程的话,
基本上内容是相同的,这里我只是展开再详细的讲述一下。那么认内交易里面的话,我们主要关注的一点就是这个便利度跟这个20均线的这个妙用。
我们知道哈,我们的便利度的存在的意义呢,不一定是百分百的整切,但是它有一定比较大概率的这种机会,会回归到我们的一个均线附近。
你要知道我们均线的一个数学的一个计算公司是什么呢,就是比如我们不同周期那么是多个周期里面的这个价格的一个算数平均或者是一种平均值。
所以说很多时候呢,我们的K线都会往往的在篇里太多这个均线的情况下呢,会回归到均线的位置。那么我们利用这个原理呢,我们去形容我们的一个机会,那么这个机会呢,我们在什么时候去发现它呢,这个时候呢,我们就用到我们的20均线。
现在就是我们在这个便利度的情况下呢,什么时候是切入的问题。那么我们先来看一下这个图示,这里的话我同样只是画出了一个下跌走势图,那么在这个图里面有三条线,分别是250均线,120均线跟这个20均线。
那么现在这个下跌的情况的话,我们这个知道哈,我们以前受到这个便利度,也就是说我们这个5分钟的K线远离我们这个250均线的这个位置,那么关于这个远离这个程度多大啊,其实这个你根据你自己的经验啊,可能是在一星期啊,或者是说半个月或者是一个月啊,那么它便利的程度大。
那么这个时候呢,我们去可以关注一下,我们去找这个任内的一个交易机会,因为这一波啊,当我们做空下来,我们这一波啊,其实也是我们的一个指引点,那也是我们可能去关注,反手去说多了这个机会的一个交易机会。
因为有时候呢,我们知道哈,小周期的均线,它往往可能是长周期均线的一些新型的指标啊,第一次一点的话,我们可能也可以去发现这个20均线的这个交易机会。
那么当我这个5分钟的K线图跌,一直跌,然后呢,现在重新站上了这个20均线,站上了这个20均线的时候,这个时候呢,我们要去关注一下。
那么因为我们记忆说我们的K线跌久了,它会回归到这个均线值的这个附近,那么我们这里这个空间也比较大,那这时候呢,我们也可以考虑去做一波啊,啊,短这个这个,之内交易的一个收益,那可能这一波的收益也是比较可观的。
那这个时候呢,我们就是这5分钟的K线站上20日均线,那么这个20日均线的话啊,也慢慢的形成一个向上清晰的角度。
那这时候呢,其实我们一般情况下吐破之后,啊,一般情况下我们考虑是回彩,回彩之身这时候呢,就是周朵,因为在我们这个,啊,均线发生反转之前呢,它有一个平滑度的,有一个弧度的,啊,它没有并没有马上就能看出出它是向上清晰的这种情况。
所以呢,我们是通用这个回,通过这个回彩有效的情况下,去发现我们这个交易机会了,那么本来回彩有效,那么这个时候我们去切入,那么在发现这个切入之后呢,它这个K线慢慢的走高,慢慢的走高,这个均线也在这个K线带东西的慢慢的向上清晰,那么这个时候呢,我们就拿着。
那么拿着的时候呢,有时候呢,它走起来的话,确实它是需要反转的,它走起来的话,它就一般情况下不会,啊,不会再吓破这个20K线一直往上走。
那么一直往上走,遇到这个120K线,那么可能还有主力回彩,那么回彩没破,那么继续拿着。同样的来到这个250K线,如果是回彩没破呢,你就继续拿着,继续拿着。
那么如果破了,那么你去做这个。那么这种情况呢,有可能是会给我们拿了一个比较大的一个,有时候呢,可能真的是进行完全的一个反转了。
像最近的这个,啊,菜破都破,大家待会我们看一下,哈,就会发现,其实这个行情很大,它可能也就是一个反转。那么如果即使没有反转,那么我们做到这个小的这个州级这个120K线,它们出现了破,那么我们没什么反正我也多少有一些盈利,那么来到250K线,那么收音这个幅度,这个反弹的幅度呢,
吃到了,我也几本吃到了,啊,所以这个问题其实不大,当阴兵我们做的是自内,我们追求的是有盈利,对吧,那么盈利的幅度大小呢,就看这个盘面的一个走势情况,啊,这个东西,啊,是否进行反转,或者是不是一定走出一个大行进,这个不是我们说的算,我们只是看着我们的技术,啊,来看着我们的盘面来做。
呃,我们现在就来看一下的一个,猜斗魄的一个情况,我现在就拿着这个斗魄的一个徒刑来说哈,呃,大家看到了哈,像我们这个猜魄,斗魄呢,每一次下跌啊,当这个幅度比较大的情况现在,它都会回产,这个250K线,回产250K线,下斗魄都比较大的都会回产,那边都会回产,所以在这个,在这个星期上周,
应该是星期三,对吧,星期三的时候那个低点,那这个时候呢,这个,你看一下,我们上破,那么回产,回产之后,没有事实,那么在重新上破的时候呢,我们这个时候就去接入了,那这个时候呢,我们去考虑做多,那么来到这里的时候呢,到了这个主力位的时候呢,确实啊,那你这个时候你觉得你不安全,你可以在这里,就在这个120K线呢,你就可以去直营了,那么如果是不放心呢,呃,
如果是说觉得你啊,不怕这个利润回测,那么你可以考虑,观察一下它这个,这个20K线是否这声有效,如果这声有效呢,那么继续拿着,来到这个250K线,一样的啊,如果是说你怕它这,那么你就会考虑这一点,那么这一个的话,它破了,那可能有些人就会去做这个直营,
但一般情况下你破了,你不用去考虑,马上去做直营,因为你下面的这个空间,你足够,足够可以让它回落,你也之后有时间去反映你的这个音力啊,保住你的一部分的音力,除了这个东西你不用,不用急,那么这个时候呢,它又回彩上去呢,那么继续走走走,对吧,就走,一直走高,一直走高,那么你到了这一点的话,可能你就最终能听得出来,那么这一波到这里波,那么其实有,呃,有100点的这个利润,那么这个空间是很大,
那么这个空间是很大的,对于这个都破一手,两千来块钱,两三千块钱的这个都破,那么其实啊,这个利润是挺高的,那我自己只举的这个是都破,啊,其实像油纸,油纸的话也挺适合用这种方式去做的,呃,用这种方式去做的,啊,油纸在中旅游啊,就把它特别喜欢用这个二十均线啊,可能这些品种的话,它确实挺适合这种,
所以呢,其实呢,就是跟大家讲的,就是说,这种方式交易的方法,技术里面交易的一些比较有效的一些技巧呢,啊,也跟大家一并的分享了,那么具体啊,那么这是以下跌的这种作为这个,呃,呃,分享,那么,呃,同样的上涨的方式呢,大家可以自己去反推一下,这里就不是再想起的这个展开奖,啊,那么有没有像大家就各起自己用这个实法机去验证了,这里就不再想起了,
就不再详细的说,呃,那么这个今天分享的内容就到这里结束,那么感谢大家如果有兴趣,请继续关注这个